the uk's broadcast regulator has revoked
the license of the russian government's
rt channel ofcom says it doesn't
consider rt
fit and proper to hold a licence and
cannot be considered a responsible
broadcaster the channel was under 29
investigations over its coverage of the
ukraine war let's go live now to london
al jazeera's nadine barber can tell us
more nadine rt is already off the air in
the uk so why has the media regulator
done this
that's right adrian since or
since uh shortly after the beginning of
the invasion of ukraine
rt has been off uh the air in terms of
its television broadcasts um and also
its youtube channel although its website
has still been accessible this decision
by ofcom the media watchdog here is with
immediate effect uh and it's it's
temporary but it is quite uh
wide-ranging
there's a statement from ofcom which has
cited new laws in russia which in
ofcom's view effectively criminalize any
independent journalism that departs from
the russian state's own news narrative
particularly over the uh war in ukraine
and ofcom says that means it appears
impossible for rt to comply with the due
impartiality rules of our broadcasting
code in the circumstances but it also
refers to 29 separate investigations
into different programs uh or news shows
uh on rt prime minister boris johnson
called for the watchdog to investigate
the broadcaster uh soon after russia
invaded ukraine there has been a
reaction from rt in the last hour the
deputy editor anna belkina has put out a
statement saying that this judgment in
effect shows that ofcom in her words is
nothing more than a tool of government
bending to its media suppressing will
and saying that the uk public are being
robbed of access to information well
ofcom did stress in their statement that
they had to
balance people's freedom of expression
and access to alternative sources of
information with retaining
trust and public confidence
in the system in the watchdog itself in
the uk's broadcasting system so
i don't think it's a decision that they
will have taken lightly uh and maybe
there's room for maneuver in the future
uh if those russian laws are actually
changed because that seems to be the
thing that's really swung this the fact
that for example russian journalists are
not allowed to refer to a war or an
invasion in ukraine al jazeera's nadine
barber reporting live from london today
many thanks indeed